hi everybody how are we today enjoying
the
conference good I love the NDC
conferences I've been doing them for
years now they're my favorite conference
and I'm not just saying that because I'm
here so uh this talk is all
about the new Javas new features of the
JavaScript language I was very excited
two years ago when I found out that
there was a new specification coming for
the JavaScript language and looking at
the JavaScript looking at that
specification I could see that this was
a huge step forward for the JavaScript
language I mean it had been years since
anything significant really meaty had
been added to the JavaScript language
and I was very excited to start working
with these new features even before the
specific ification was Final and that
was possible because back then when it
was still called ecmascript 6 there were
transpilers available so I could start
writing this code into projects and not
really worry about it screwing up in
production because the transpilers would
just put it into es5 code and I knew
everything would work in the browser so
that was all great but it's been two
years now of working with some of these
new features and I've discovered that um
just like ancient cartographers when
they were drawing out maps of the world
there are some of those areas that just
haven't been fully
explored uh areas where ships just kind
of disappear we don't know why so they
used to draw dragons and other myth
mythological beasts on the map just to
represent those areas where you need to
be a little bit cautious if you're
venturing into that area so my goal in
this presentation is maybe you've looked
at some of these features or using some
of these features maybe not but over the
last two years I've picked up on areas
where developers run into problems and
where things don't work like you would
expect them to work and we will start as
an example with arrow functions how hard
could they be they're actually one of
the one of those features of ecmascript
2015 where I've seen people struggle the
most so I'll also give you a little bit
of an overview of what these
specifications are just in case you
haven't worked with some of these new
languages but if you're a c developer
error functions are just like Lambda EX
in C almost identical the rules are
almost the same for example this first
bit of code here that represents an
executable function
which I think my computer just
uh got very
unhappy
again yeah there we
go strange patterns on the
screen so I think I might have to reboot
real
quick one second I'm GNA focus on this
for just a second and as soon as I get
back up and
running I
will yeah I'm G to have to completely
reboot that's uh
unfortunate you know another laptop
might not be a bad
idea I'll just have to get the slides
off of one drive or something I'll try
it once more here but while this is
rebooting let me just tell you
that Arrow functions are almost just
like the functions uh Lambda expressions
in C that is if I want to write an arrow
function that only takes one parameter I
have to do a hard reset here I don't
need parentheses around that parameter
but if I have an error function that
takes two parameters I need the
parentheses and all of this would look
glorious if it was actually on the
screen interesting that it did that when
I put the pen on the screen to annotate
it we'll try it one more time here we're
almost
there see if we get a
[Music]
display yes
okay see me log
in let me
try to bring this
up press that button carefully let's try
the pen real
quick okay so far so good no one
breathe
this is defining a piece of executable
code that takes one parameter X and it
goes to the expression x x x so just
like in C if I just want to write a
simple expression that's going to be the
return result I don't need a return
statement I don't need curly braces or
anything like that add is taking two
parameters X and Y that'll return X Plus
Y and again we're we're defining
something that I can execute so I can
say Square the result of adding three
and five and log that out it would be a
64 error functions are beautiful because
JavaScript is a very functional language
there's lots of apis that are higher
order functions so they're functions
that you can pass in other functions to
do work
a good example is the map function
that's now available on an array instead
of saying numbers. map function keyword
parentheses and all that noise that used
to be in JavaScript I can now just say
numbers. map and here's a little Lambda
expression and goes to n * 2 so I'll
double everything in the re array so
aror functions look good but they are
it's important to note that aror
functions are not a replacement for the
function keyword there's a couple places
where you cannot use error functions
it's syntactically illegal for example
to use Arrow functions to define a class
member and then there's other places
where Arrow functions just don't work
like you would expect so let's talk
about a few of those scenarios and
here's one scenario that comes up here's
a piece of code right here where someone
is saying I want to take these numbers
and I want to map them into
objects where I would expect to get back
three objects that would be value colon
one value colon 2 value colon 3 but what
I will actually get back is an array
with three undefined values in it
because when the JavaScript runtime
evaluates this expression with the um
curly braces it doesn't see that as me
trying to return an object literal it
sees that as me trying to open up a code
block to perform some work and with once
you start a code block with curly braces
you do need an explicit return statement
if I wanted to return value colon n for
everything in that array so what
JavaScript sees is some code that it
executes and returns undefined how is
that even syntactically
legal it's still syntactically legal
because technically JavaScript we don't
use this very often but it does have uh
labels in the language you can add a
label to a line of code so what
JavaScript is seeing there is a label
called value that just points to the
expression n but it it doesn't produce
the result we want so don't do that the
easy fix in that particular case yes I
could use an explicit return statement
and I can also wrap this thing with
parentheses and then the JavaScript run
time will say oh okay what you really
want here is an expression that is an
object literal and build an object that
has a value property and I'll Stick n
inside of there from the array so then
I'd get back value one value two value
three making sense interesting hopefully
this is what you came to see
good the other special characteristic
about error functions that you probably
know if you've worked with this feature
is how they preserve the lexical this
reference so here's an example of an
object that will not work
correctly because when I say numbers.
for each here's a function please add n
to sum what is the this
reference well it's not going to be
pointing to this Adder object that I'm
inside
of because the this reference we know in
JavaScript it's Dynamic it's slippery
it's set up by the call contact so when
for each calls my function for each
isn't going to call my function and pass
in n and set up the this reference for
me appropriately so this is probably
referencing the window object and I'm
going to be getting an error cannot read
property sum if I try to execute that
code one of the things they did with
arrow functions which is kind of
borrowed from copy script fat arrows is
that when you define an arrow function
it's going to preserve the lexical value
of the this reference and other other
words since this Arrow function is
defined inside of a function that is
inside of this object and assuming add
gets invoked correctly this Arrow
function is always always always going
to be using a this reference that is
exactly the same as the this reference
that would be outside of the arrow
function inside this
function
so am I making sense no what's
wrong just that expression
okay yes yes
yes a little jet lag so I'm a little
leery about what I might be doing wrong
here on front of the stage um that Cod
will work so that will actually refer to
this. sum and I will get back a result
that is equal to six which is what I
would expect that's nice and it's very
useful in a number of scenarios but it's
also you have to be aware that it can be
dangerous in a couple scenarios I'll
explain why in just a minute
um but before I get there this code
works just so we're clear that's an
arrow function that's being defined
inside of a function so it will capture
that this reference and the
specification talks about the this
reference becoming static it's no longer
dynamically determined it's sort of
pre-bound into that Arrow function and
no one can change
it but what about this bit of
code where I have this this object
member defined as an arrow function and
an error function inside of there it's
not immediately obvious when you write
that code you might say well I I have an
error function here and it's inside my
object but the scope for that will be
taken from the scope from this Arrow
function and the scope of this for this
Arrow the scope of this for that line of
code it's not inside of a function uh so
it's whatever this is right here where
that's being luxly defined so I could
very easily be ending up with a this
reference that is still pointing to the
window object or you know whatever this
was inside of whatever that object was
inside of is that making some sense so
too many Arrow functions
there and then the other thing to keep
in mind about aror functions is that you
cannot bind apply or call to change the
this reference any longer so any other
normal function in JavaScript that's
declar with the function keyword I can
get a reference to that function I can
say function. bind here your this
reference to use or function. apply I'm
going to invoke this function and pass
in your this reference but with error
functions it does not work once the this
once the this pointer has been captured
by the error function there's nothing
you can do to change it so in this
example I have my object adder and now
I'm trying to Define an arrow function
that I'm going to bind onto that Adder
so I'm trying to say here's what you'll
use as a this reference but it's not
going to work react programmers run into
this a lot because they try to Define
functions and bind them to the object
that they're going to uh be working with
and when they Define them using Arrow
functions they can run into trouble what
are some other scenarios where you run
into trouble with that
well let me start with this second
example actually if you're using jQuery
it's quite common to wire up like a
button click event and then when jQuery
invokes your callback function because
it's been clicked jQuery will try to set
up the this reference so it can pass it
in as the Dom element that was clicked
on unfortunately jQuery won't be able to
do that any longer if you define the
call back as an arrow function because
again you can't use uh function. bind or
call or apply to manipulate the this
reference anymore so this piece of code
the this reference will not be the one
that jQuery tried to set up for you
it'll be whatever it captured inside of
whatever whatever scope we're in so
instead of setting name on the Dom
element chances are you're setting the
name of the window or the name of the
module or something like that the place
where I first ran into this and
discovered it much to my dismay was
inside of Jasmine unit test I thought
well this is really nice I'll just start
defining my unit test as Arrow functions
but if you've ever used Jasmine you can
set up a test context in Jasmine and
attach things to a this reference inside
of like before each
calls uh just to keep track of things
and have them available inside of the it
throughout all of your
tests and then Jasmine when it invokes
this function to execute the unit test
it tries to set up the this pointer so
you can get to the test context but if
it's an arrow function you don't get the
test context so I had test failing and
trying to figure out why and I thought
maybe it was a bug in the transpiler and
that's when I actually dug into the
JavaScript specification and saw oh this
is actually how error functions work and
I also found out then when I looked in
the specification Arrow functions have a
couple other um idiosyncrasies let's
call them because they're not normal
functions they don't have their own
implicit arguments variable whatever the
arguments are there will be whatever the
arguments were for maybe the function
I'm inside of so if I try to add three
and five even though I'm passing in two
things this implicit arguments variable
here would return zero because maybe I'm
inside of a function that had zero
arguments is that making some sense so
don't rely on some of those typical
function behaviors and implicit
variables that you would get when you're
using Arrow
functions let's talk about template
literals for a second template literals
are that new feature in ecmascript 2015
where I can use the back tick so not a
single quote not a double quote but a
back tick and then the JavaScript
runtime will evaluate the dollar sign
curly brace Expressions that are inside
of the
string and if I had X and Y defined
before I reach that exact line of code
JavaScript would produce something like
3 + 5al 8 because it would actually
evaluate all this stuff but a lot of
people when they hear the word templates
they think naturally that oh okay I can
define a template like this and then
reuse it with different objects so I'd
be able to define a template and then
later on give it some X or Y and tell it
to format itself but that's not how it
works it's literally just in line there
when you define the template any of the
variables that you are using inside of
that template they have to be available
in the scope and the JavaScript runtime
if it doesn't find X or Y it'll say
something is not
defined and then people say well why are
they templates then why don't we just
call the string inter
interpolation well the original
specifications for this actually called
them quasi literals so they're kind of
fake literals they're not really
literals but it's JavaScript so it has
to be a little bit quirky right um You
can make them reusable though so here
I'm just going to define template now as
a function that takes takes two
parameters X and Y and it
Returns the template literal X+ y = X+ Y
and so now all I have to do is invoke
that function and pass in my model data
so invoke template pass in two and two
and I get back the string 2 plus 2al
4 and if you want to get a little bit
fancier you can use a feature in
ecmascript 2015 known as destructuring
so this syntax right here I don't have a
slide on D structuring I don't think
uh curly brackets on the left hand side
of an assignment statement or in the
list of parameters to a function they
destructure an object so this is
creating two variables X and Y and what
it will do is pull the X property and
the Y property out of an object that I
pass
in and so now I have the ability to
invoke this template and sort of pass in
a model object right I pass in an object
that has some properties and there's a
template literally on there that'll spit
it out so now it feels a little more
templ feels a little more like
handlebars or something like
that CRA So speaking of
destructuring some people don't like the
crazy syntax that you can now do with
ecmascript 2015 and uh plus some other
features in the future and actually I do
have here something on destructuring so
what is destructuring to structuring
strike some people as funny
but square brackets on the right hand
side of an assignment that's
constructing something so I'm
constructing an array using an array
literal square brackets on the left hand
side of an assignment is destructuring
so it's creating new variables X and Y
and then it's trying to pull in this
case element Sub Zero and element sub
one out of whatever is on the right hand
side so I would get out of this bit of
code X is 22 and Y is 44 very good that
one's a simple
example but you can get a little bit
weirder so here's an example where I
have an object with and so there's a
radi structuring and there's object
destructuring object destructuring well
object literals are when you have curly
brackets on the right hand side of an
expression object destructuring is when
you have the curly brackets on the left
hand side of an assignment so this is
actually creating two new variables
State and
Country state is going to have a default
value of New York but it it's also going
try to try to read the state property
out of address since there is a state
here of Maryland that's where I live in
the United States the result of this
would be State the state would be
pointing to a string Maryland uh country
however since there's no country in my
address object it would be get that
default value of USA so that's where
people start to feel a little bit
uncomfortable with the structuring why
don't we just write the code a little
more
explicitly um but then you can also do
do really crazy stuff with it so here's
an object literal defining an employee
with a first name it's a complex object
cuz I have an address inside of there
state Maryland Country USA my favorite
numbers not really but whatever this is
a destructuring assignment down here
because the curly braces are on the Le
hand side I'm trying to pull out the
first name property fine that'll be
equal to a Scott this is defining a
state variable it's going to drill into
the address of the employee and pull out
the state of Maryland and this little
quirky expression here is saying go into
favorite numbers skip the first element
of the array pull out the second one
that would be a
55 so now I have three new variables
first name State and second and they
would be equal to Scott Maryland and 55
that's a little bit odd until you're
used to it but it gets better or weirder
depending on how you think about it um
what's this
produce
yeah it's a variable length and since a
string has a length property we'll be
getting the length of that string out of
it which is uh looks to be four right WT
question mark four
characters even more
interesting I'm going to put a couple
different operators together so first of
all you might have heard of the bang
bang operator Bang Bang You're a Boolean
it's a way to do a type coercion in
JavaScript so I want to know if value is
true so first I'll knot it to get it
into a Boolean but that's the opposite
of what I want so I'll knot it again to
get a true
out so let's combine that with uh some
other syntax so what is this syntax this
is the spread syntax that's part of
ecmascript
2015 spreading allows me to take an
array and then spit out the individual
elements of that array into another
array I can also use it when I invoke a
function to take an array and spread the
array across the parameters to that
function so if I wanted to invoke a
function that took three parameters I
could invoke it and do dot dot dot
numbers and one would go to the first
parameter two would go to the second
parameter three to the third parameter
but in this example I'm taking numbers
and spreading them into an array so I'll
get back in Array 1 2 3 4 5 six kind of
like
flattening now in the next version of
ecmascript which you can already take
advantage of because transpilers like
Babble allow you to uh turn on features
that aren't part of an official
specification yet they're still coming
in the future but in the a future
specification you can also spread
objects so I want to take this data
object and then I want to build a new
object result that'll have some
additional data in it but spread data
into it so result will actually have X
and Y properties after that is
evaluated making sense so
far so now I can't can't remember what
library this is in I can't remember if
it's in redu it seems to me it's
something uh react related what in Earth
does this
do
well what it's trying to do is first
determine the spread operator has a very
low priority first determine if there is
data or not the not not data and if
there is data the result of that will be
uh this piece of the tary expression and
the dot dot dot means we will spread
data into this result and the whole goal
of this is that if we don't have data
what I want to spread here is this false
condition which is I just want to spread
in default is true into that object but
a lot of people look at this dot dot dot
bang
bang and start to say maybe things have
gone too far I don't
know but that's actually in a a GitHub
project if you do some
searching what about this const keyword
I've been using const and let were
introduced in ecmascript 2015 and a lot
of people these days are saying use
const whenever possible that should be
your default when you're declaring a
variable use const and const means means
no more assignments to that variable and
it makes it easier to reason about uh
use let if you have to do an assignment
but const what it should do is if I def
Define a variable x equals 2 but then I
try to reassign it somewhere later in
the code I should get a type error I'm
trying to assign to a constant variable
so in this case if this is really
something I had to do I I should be
using let here or maybe even VAR but
just so you know const doesn't mean
immutable so I cannot declare constant
numbers equal some array literal and
expect that to prevent someone from
pushing or popping or slicing that
array that
works if that's something I wanted to do
I could use the object. freeze API you
know that would prevent someone from
pushing something in that would generate
a type error should generate a type
error and let's talk about collections a
little bit so they did do some good new
things to prevent crazy errors in
JavaScript you know if you invoke the
array function and you pass in three
parameters that will give you back an
array that has those parameters as um
values in the
array but if you invoke the array
function and only pass in one thing it
assumes you want an array of that size
so it doesn't build an array with a 10
in it it builds an array with 10
undefined in it and that becomes a
problem that's actually something that
I've seen people run into when they're
doing a little bit of dynamic
programming and uh doing AR ray. call
and they're not sure how many parameters
they might have to pass in U just so you
know if you're ever in that
situation there is now an array. of
which is the API you should be
using when you really want to create an
array given some parameters and it takes
a a VAR ARS it takes a variable number
of arguments so I could pass in 10 11 12
and it will build me an array with 10 11
and 12 in
it and what's interesting about uh
there's another one array. from which is
uh actually kind of odd what it will do
is it will look at this object that you
pass in the first parameter to see if
it's iterable or to see if it has a
length property and if it just has has a
length property internally it just sets
up a loop from I equals 0 to I is less
than
length and uh in this case I'm just
demonstrating that you can also pass in
a callback function that takes the value
that it found at that
index and the indexing the key that it
used to get in there like 0 1 two three
or four five um so what this would do is
just build build actually an array that
has the value 0 1 2 3 4 in it
fascinating I hear you say tell me more
all
right there's some new data structures
in ecmascript 2015 uh you should just be
aware of how they work there's a new set
so sets shouldn't have duplicates in
them but it's just doing a reference or
a Val value comparison where um if I
create a new set and try to add nine
twice there'll only be one nine in there
which makes
sense but if I try to add two arrays
that's two different objects that the
set sees so it's going to happily accept
the two different arrays and the set
size will be two makes sense I to a lot
of people when they see this I think
right you just have to be aware that
that is the
behavior if I were to try to add the
same object reference twice so the same
array I try to add twice then the set do
size would just contain the one just
contain that array wouldn't add it
twice a lot of people have asked over
the last year if there's a literal
notation for map or set map is another
new type that was defined by ecmascript
2015 we have a array literals and this
nice syntax to create an array is there
something similar for map or set and the
answer is uh no we have array literals
we have object literals and that's still
just the only literals we have if I want
to create a new map this is sort of the
quirky syntax to create a map um I pass
in Array an array of
arrays where each array inside of here
contains the key value uh the key and
then the value for
IT classes this is where things start to
get
interesting
again so typically when people are
teaching ecmascript 2015 or describing
these features they tell you that
classes are syntactic sugar for for what
we've always done in other words if I
define a class with a Constructor and
and it has some methods like do work and
it has a property like get and set Name
Behind the Scenes all that really is
doing is just what we used to do which
is let me Define a Constructor function
and then let me modify the Prototype
object of that Constructor function and
add some members to it because every
object that is instantiated from that
Constructor function will have its magic
prototype reference point to that
prototype object therefore every object
that is instantiated from this
Constructor function will have do a do
work method and a name property that has
a getter and Setter and for the most
part this is true for the most part you
can think of classes this way that when
I'm rting a class it's really just
behind the scenes desugared into what
I've always been doing perhaps if you've
ever used this approach to JavaScript
programming if you you know like the
object-oriented style but there are some
important differences between
implementing employee using this style
and implementing employee using using
this style one such difference is in
hoisting so if you're familiar with the
term hoisting in JavaScript you
typically associate it with evil Powers
right it's not something that we
typically like but it does allow me to
write code like this I can define a
function down here at the bottom of my
Javascript file but thanks to hoisting
that symbol employee is actually
available right from the start when I am
executing code at the top of this file
therefore if I write code that says Cony
equals new employee that's going to work
just fine even though I have employee
defined
below the same is not true for classes
if I try to define a class at the bottom
of the file because it's a utility class
and I kind of want to push it out of the
site and do some real work at the top um
this is not going to work it's going to
throw a reference air
classes classes actually do hoist but
they're but they're not legal to use
when they hoist hoist so you should get
a reference air for
this and so what do I mean when I say
classes hoist but they're not available
to use there's this wonderful term in
the ecmascript 2015 specification they
talk about this thing called the
temporal Dead Zone the
tdz I think is a fantastic name for a
movie the temporal Dead
Zone but what they're talking about is
that there is a period of time
where and here's another example
let VAR variables hoist right if I have
if I was using VAR xal 2 x is available
everywhere inside of that function right
that's what hoisting does but if I
declare that variable x with let like it
here is here on the slide technically X
is hoisted it is avilable right from the
top of the
function but the specification also says
that that is a temporal dead zone until
you reach the line of code where X is
actually formly declared with let or
const if anyone tries to access X the
runtime has to throw a reference err so
yeah
JavaScript another difference uh if I
Define employee or human well the
example here is I'm defining a
Constructor function human I'm
manipulating the prototype to add a do
work method to humans that are
instantiated from that Constructor
function
if I want to do some reflection that is
iterate through a new human and find out
what is available inside the fourin loop
will give me back do work as an
available thing inside of a
human but if I Define human or well in
this case horse as a
class and I try to for in through a new
horse that method is not seen so you
cannot reflect as easily over something
that has been defined with a class and
that trips people I've seen that trip PE
I've seen that trip people up a bit what
if I really wanted to do that what if I
really wanted to for in over a horse and
find out what's inside of it well I
can't exactly for in but what I can do
is I can use object. prototype of an
instance of a
horse and then there's an API object.
getet own property names on that thing
that I get back from get prototype of um
um and this is if I want to find the
available methods on an object that
would actually tell me uh in add in
addition to do work actually that would
tell me about the Constructor too so
it's telling me yes there's a
Constructor there and there's a thing
called do work there so slight different
API this is a four of loop by the way
how many people know four
of just a few so for in has always been
in JavaScript and it iterates over the
available keys that are in an object or
in an array four of actually pulls out
values so if I four of over an array I
actually get the values that are inside
whereas for in gives me the indexes and
I have to use them to index into the
array so four of is nice new is required
so paranoid JavaScript developers of the
past when they Ed the construct when
they wrote Constructor functions quite
often they wrote some defensive
programming in there that used operators
like instance of to make sure that no
one was invoking the Constructor uh
without using the new keyword but in
ecmascript 2015 you don't have to do
that if you write a class and someone
tries to invoke The Constructor for that
class and I don't have one defined here
but it wouldn't matter even if I had a
Constructor there so that's that's the
word
Constructor uh with curly
braces I would get a typ air if I tried
to uh invoke hor course without using
the new keyword so I don't have to do
that anymore but this being JavaScript
what's interesting is I can define a
Constructor and still return whatever
the heck I
want and that works and that's
legal because it's
JavaScript so I say new horse and I get
back something with a name of Jiffy and
no do work method
right let's talk about modules so I have
to tell you when I first looked at the
specification and I saw that there was
going to be modules in JavaScript I
thought yes my prayers have been
answered I've been wanting something
like this for 10 years now you know
every other language I work with c and
Java in the past and Python and Ruby and
everything has some ability to
encapsulate code and modularize it and
spread things across the file system and
I don't have to uh do weird things in
the language just to uh architecturally
hook things up to work these days is
there are times when I look at modules
and I think yes I am being punished for
what I have asked for that's a quote
from Oscar wild he uh any Oscar wild
fans out there he writes some really
wonderful Pros
um English fellow and he's written plays
and books and all sorts of interesting
things you I'm sure you've probably seen
a movie or something that was inspired
by one of his
works so what are modules in EAS script
2015 um first of all they're beautiful
because because when I write code that
is targeting ecmascript 2015 I no longer
have to worry about this syntactic noise
that litters every. JS file out there no
more iies to control scope uh no more
use strict because an ecmascript 2015 if
you're in a module you are in a strict
mode by default all of that goes away I
can open up ajs file and just start
writing code and I don't have to worry
about anything leaking out into the
global scope by default doesn't happen
anymore
instead I can start writing things in a
file and I can pick what I explicitly
want to export to the outside world for
them to consume so inside of this file
if I write a function work unless I
explicitly export that thing no one else
can see it no one else can use it no one
else can touch it and I can either
export it by using the export keyword
right there so I could say export
function work and it would be published
some people like to write all their code
and then put their exports down at the
bottom so they're easy to find you just
always scroll to the bottom of the file
Ah that's what I'm exporting so here I'm
exporting two things exporting work
exporting the person class you can
export functions you can export classes
you can export variables you can export
just about everything and ecmascript
2015 also has a a slightly diffusing uh
diffusing
confusing um concept of a default export
which I'll talk about here in just a
second but it's basically a way of
saying all right if someone wants to
import from me and they haven't
specified exactly what they want to
import they get the person class that's
basically what that syntax is
saying there's also a syntax that allows
you to roll things up uh and this is
quite useful if you're building a
library or you want to build an API it's
even quite useful inside of applications
sometimes um this is basically saying
hey take everything from this module
creatures and Export it and also take
everything from the humans modules and
Export it and so now I have a module
that other people can work with without
knowing about these lower level modules
creatures and humans and referring to
them directly modules by the way if you
haven't seen the syntax before you don't
have to specify a file extension but
this is literally saying uh in this
folder there should be a creatures. JS
file and that's what where I want to
grab exports from so you can use uh pass
and relative path to navigate to the the
modules that you
want and then there's Imports so when
someone has exported something I can
import things so I can import person and
animal from lib these names have to
match the names that are being exported
so if someone exported person I have to
import
person be very careful if you forget to
use the curly braces because if you
don't have the curly braces you're
asking for the default export and so
I've seen a lot of people use the import
statement and this thing is undefined
and they don't know why because hey that
module I see it exports a human person
but unless it's an a default
export do I have enough pen markup on
here yet unless it's a default export um
you don't get anything
here and if they do have a default
export you can name this whatever you
want so they could be exporting F and I
could be importing bar and it would work
there's also the ability to just say I
going to import everything and this
becomes kind of like a name space so
import everything put it in this lib
variable and now I can say lib do this
or li. person li.
animal fast needing I hear you
say so some important behaviors to
understand about this first of all um
let me back up a
second it's very so when I first looked
at the syntax I thought oh this is quite
clever I can imagine this thing
exporting some sort of module object and
this over here is doing a destructuring
so what I'm doing is creating a local
variable called animal and it's just
sort of destructured out of that module
that's not what's that's not what's
happening at all the specification
refers to these as bindings it is not
destructuring and here's why that's
significant let's say I have a module
that exports a simple variable counter
equals zero and it also exports a
function that I can use to increment
that counter and add one to
it some other module Imports that
counter and tries to manipulate it
that's a Sy tax here because these
bindings are you can think of them as
const they're immutable I cannot change
counter and you might say well you know
am I getting a copy of that counter
what's really happening here it's it's
really quite bizarre until you uh sit
down and think through it and look at
the specification you would think A
Primitive value like a number you would
be getting a copy of it in this other
module but that's actually not what's is
not what's happening if I import count
and increment I can look at counter and
it's a zero ah sorry and if I if I
invoke
increment which is jumping back into
this module to increment this counter I
see that change in my other module you
can all so so don't think of these as
simple variables think of them think of
them as bindings and they're almost like
the C++ developers a pointer to a
pointer you know I'm getting a pointer
to that other number that's over there
and when I look at count counter I'm I'm
referring to that counter really that's
in that other
module uh yes
sorry and think of it like a Singleton
so they'll all see the same counter yep
the question was uh if if I imported it
somewhere else into a second module you
know does it see that same value for
counter and the answer is yes you can
almost think of this like a Singleton
and each each module gets a binding to
it and the bindings are alive so a
slightly different example we're going
to have an we're going to export an
object now with the name of
Oscar uh and then just some functions to
do things like reset to a new object and
uh inspect the name that that module
knows about this behaves pretty much
like you would probably expect I can set
the creature's name when I import
creature that's an immutable binding but
creature. name is just a property on
that thing so I can change the
name and if I
uh
look in that other module you know what
name does it see it sees Winnie because
my module changed
it uh and if I reset things that resets
my binding so my creature goes be go
goes back to being named Oscar because
now we're looking at this
object making
sense what's the default value of this
inside of a module it's undefined just
so you know
unlike uh when you're not inside of a
module and this is the window object or
you know something
else uh so you might be looking at this
and saying well Scott why do you feel
punished when you're using
modules it's because the uh ecmascript
2015 specification was very clear that
they wanted a static Syntax for
modules um and you can get into
situations where you start importing a
lot of things or you do a lot of
bookkeeping right this is actually from
a unit test in the angular 2
framework where we're trying to write
tests using e script 2015 2015 modules
first we have to import uh things from
the test framework then we have to
import some of our infrastructure that
helps us test things then we have to
import the things that we actually want
to test uh and then we have to import
some other helpers down here so there's
what 40 some lines of imports before I
even get to the test code now that's an
extreme example but um it can sometimes
feel tiresome you just want to use this
thing that's in another file and it used
to be so easy in JavaScript but now I
have to manage these Imports to actually
formally bring it in and I would expect
over time tooling is going to help us
solve this I know jet brains webstorm
already has a feature where if you just
type that you're using creature it'll
say oh do you want me to add an import
statement for it you know which is kind
of
nice but you and if you come from a
node.js background or if you've ever
used commonjs or any of these other
module informal module specifications
Community Based specifications that have
been out there for modules you might say
well can I do something Dynamic like
this is the kind of code people write
might write with node to say I want to
go out and um require
sorry down here I want to require a
bunch of files that I find so I just
want to write some code to go in a
directory Loop through all the files
that are find there files that are found
there and dynamically import
them that doesn't work with ecmascript
2015 uh again the specification when
they were um designing the module Syntax
for JavaScript they didn't want Dynamic
stuff they wanted modules to be very
explicit and very static and give tools
the ability to parse a JavaScript file
and analyze the import statements
without actually executing JavaScript
code and they felt that that would
enable a number of good tooling benefits
as well as a number of good runtime
optimizations so modules feel a little
bit inflexible sometimes you don't have
any wiggle room you have to specify
specific module names and import
specific symbols that you
want the other interesting thing about
modules is that the module syntax that
we're looking at is complete and written
in stone and it's not going to change it
is officially part of the
specification what the specification
does not provide any guidance on however
is how those statements should actually
behave in a browser or an environment or
an environment like no. JS they
basically say here's the syntax now you
guys figure out what's going to happen
which
means it's impossible to use any of this
code without without running through a
tool that will stitch together modules
for you you know you have to use a
transpiler you have to use a tool that's
going to emit code that will work in the
browser and get rid of the import
statements right now there's two and
this is another big source of pain for
me with modules originally when I
started working with modules I selected
this tool called
systemjs systemjs is a tool that gives
you an API like hey I want to
dynamically import this module it's
going to be the main entry point for my
application and once systemjs brings
that file in it might see that that
main.js file Imports some other things
so and it'll just go out and grab
everything that you need and can it can
do it all dynamically too just fetch
things the reason I initially wanted to
use system.js is because systemjs
systemjs says that um or the whole goal
behind systemjs is that it's trying to
implement the future specification for
how module loaders should behave so
someday in the future or perhaps when
our grandchildren are
programming there will be a finished
specification for how module loading
works and systemjs should reflect
exactly what that specification says my
frustrations with systemjs are
that it is not a finished specification
it still changes and apis change and you
can do you can have a perfectly working
system one morning and then do an npm
update and get a new version of systemjs
and all hell breaks loose nothing
works so I've kind of been off of
systemjs for about six months now I
might revisit it next year when things
are better or you know cool closer
perhaps uh so one problem with systemjs
is changing standards another problem is
performance actually uh the aelia team
ran into the
systemjs since it's trying to follow the
specifications it builds on top of
specifications like the promise
specification so when you try to import
a module it'll return a promise and you
can wait for that promise to resolve to
know hey my module has now arrived in
the browser unfortunately some browsers
uh and systemjs I should mention when
it's loading a large application it's
building up hundreds perhaps thousands
of promises to do all this resolution
work and in some browsers promises don't
perform very well I think it was
Internet Explorer that was taking uh
some version of Internet Explorer would
take 6 minutes to load an application
where in Chrome it was 100 milliseconds
and it was all because of the the uh
promise implementation in Internet
Explorer they actually had a regression
bug that was causing a problem so it's
not a perfect world I I moved away from
systemjs and for the last uh about six
months I've been using a tool called
weback webpack is one of a number of
tools that understand ecmascript 2015
modules it understands commonjs modules
it understands AMD modules it
understands UMD modules it knows how to
work with typescript and babble and all
the transpilers it's just one of those
Swiss army knife tools that does
everything a lot of people use webpack
and completely replace things like Grunt
and gulp because you can use webpack to
make an entire build
system and the whole essence of webpack
is that it's a tool that you're going to
run at uh build time so before things
get to the browser and then you're going
to tell it here's the entry point for my
application please go to entry. JS web
packo look at that file see that it has
a couple import statements it'll say
okay let me go to those files and they
have import statements so again it just
goes through the tree of dependencies
puts all the JavaScript files together
into a single one or uh you can build
multiple files too if you want uh in
this case we'd be doing a single output
into a file called bundle.js
and voila you know everything's resolved
and I don't have to worry about a
runtime module loader or any of that
stuff webpack has just given me
JavaScript that I can put into the
browser using regular script tags and
everything works and again webpack is
just one of those tools that slices and
dices and does everything so if I want
webpack to package up my CSS files and
my HTML templates and fonts and all this
other stuff it'll put everything
together uh even if it has to
um base 64 en code things so webpack is
cool but I do have some concerns over
webpack uh I I've seen a tendency in
some
applications where the uh the
application code becomes webpack
ified uh a good example would be this is
a piece of angular 2 code which
everything appears normal here but I
want to point out this require statement
that require statement is not an angular
API it's not a browser API it's nothing
that no one understands but webpack
understand understands it so when
webpack is processing this uh ecmascript
2015 or typescript file it can see that
require and say oh you want to bring in
an HTML template let me also build that
into your uh Javascript file so
everything's put together and that's
nice because now my application can be
served from perhaps just a s single file
I don't have to send down templates and
all this other stuff but it always
worries me when applications take a
dependency on tools because
in the world of JavaScript how long do
tools stick
around you know Bower was a pretty hot
tool like three years ago how many
people still use it I mean there there's
a lot of people that still use it but
you know how many of the cool kids still
use
it I've also seen library and framework
authors struggle with modules and
dependencies I mean I'm building let's
say I want to build bu a framework on
ecmascript 2015 how do I publish that to
other people to use um and do I need to
build things ahead of time do I need to
compile everything to the universal
module definition that works with all
sorts of different modules except uh
ecmascript 2015 modules and what do I do
about the poly fills that are required
do I build them into my library or do I
force you to load them in the browser
there's just all sorts of crazy things
that go on with modules and then the
Tooling in the space that you need
things like webpack and the transpilers
and all the uh PM this install this and
mpm install that to me it's often like
being on the ship that's on that ocean
right there there are some days that are
very exciting you're living on the edge
you're swirling around in the ocean and
everything is great and it's just so
exciting and then there's days where you
get like really close to that hole and
you just think the whole Project's going
down and you're going to die and you
just want to get out of this world and
get back to something sane like CP or
something you know something that
someone has thought through uh perhaps
excluding as p. in core but
anyway it's nuts things break all the
time so if you are going to embark on
something that's going to use ecmascript
2015 I hope I haven't scared you I hope
I have just prepared you it will be the
future and if you do it today yeah maybe
things are still a little bit early so
you're going to experience some pain um
the biggest pain to me really is the
tooling and setting up a build process
and all of that is extremely uh
complicated and brittle and fragile
anyway I'm going to be sticking around
for questions I'll let you go since it's
uh last session of the day you probably
want to get out of here and do something
interesting but if you want to contact
me that's my email address I can send
you the slides or whatever that's me on
Twitter that's my website that's where I
do videos and uh I think ssw is holding
some ask me anything session downstairs
with me after this so if you want to
come down there I can answer questions
there thank you for coming out have a
great
conference